عندما بدأت التدوين ، لاحظت أنه
لا يوجد مدونون يشبهونني
سواء كانوا من جنوب آسيا حيث
كانوا عرب ، سواء كانوا
يعرفون اللغة الفارسية التركية مهما كان ،
لم يكن هناك أي شخص يمكنني
النظر إليه وهذا أحد الأسباب
لماذا بدأت في التدوين ، لذلك كان الأمر كذلك
بالنسبة لهذا
النوع من النساء في الشرق الأوسط ، أعتقد أن فلسفتنا
وروحنا تدور تمامًا حول
جعل الناس يشعرون بتحسن ويشعرون
بالرضا والثقة ، وهذا هو المكان الذي
يأتي فيه كل شيء من الجمال يتعلق
بالشعور بالرضا.  الجمال هي علامة تجارية
بدأت حقًا كمصدر لكل شخص ما
تمر به النساء الحقيقيات وللتحقيق نوعًا ما
من الصدق حيال ذلك ، ثم
أصبحت في النهاية علامة تجارية نفكر فيها
دائمًا بأنفسنا
كمستهلكين نريد تحسين المعايير
التي نريدها  لتغيير العالم ولسنا على
استعداد للتخلي عن ذلك
عندما قررنا بالفعل إنشاء
الأساس ، فقد كان ذلك منذ وقت طويل في
الوقت الذي تعرف فيه العلامات التجارية هناك  كان عدد قليل جدًا من
العلامات التجارية التي تحتوي على العديد من الظلال ،
فقد كانت عملية عاطفية للغاية لأنها
شعرت وكأنك تعلم أنك إذا كنت ظلًا معينًا
لم تكن جزءًا من
المحادثة ، لذا فأنت تعلم أننا
سعينا حقًا لمحاولة صنع العديد من النغمات
من الممكن أن يحدث التغيير ،
والمحادثة تلقى صدى لدى الناس ،
لكنها مهمة طويلة المدى ، فقد أتيحت لنا
العديد من الفرص لمجرد أخذ
اسمنا ووضعه على المنتجات الجاهزة
وقد قلنا دائمًا لا لأننا
مثل هذا ليس ما نؤمن به
نحن حقًا فيه من أجل الجودة
وأحيانًا لا يتعلق الأمر دائمًا بعلامتنا
التجارية ، كما تعلمون ، ما هو مضحك للغاية
لأنني أعتقد أننا كنا محظوظين
بالعثور على مستثمرين يفهمون أننا
لا نتحدث دائمًا  حول
منتجنا الذي تعرفه ، ولكن الأمر يتعلق حقًا
ببناء هذا المجتمع القوي حقًا من
الأشخاص الذين يمكنهم حقًا الاعتماد علينا.
لمعرفة ما إذا كنت من الشرق الأوسط
أم لا ، ربما تحب جمال الشرق الأوسط
الذي تعرفه مع الشرق الأوسط
بشكل عام ، ما لا
نفرط فيه أبدًا ، لا نحبه أبدًا ،
ولكن الآن أضف القليل من النساء
هنا  من المدهش أن تكون سيدة أعمال
في الشرق الأوسط وكونك
سيدة أعمال بشكل عام خاصة ما
كان سابقًا في عالم الرجل ، كان ذلك يمثل
تحديًا أعتقد في
البداية أننا عوملنا على هذا النحو كان
هواية ولم نكن نعرف ما كنا
نفعله ونحن  عرفنا جيدًا أننا عرفنا حقًا
كيف تبلي ، ونأمل أن تعلم أننا
سنصبح العلامة التجارية الأولى للجمال
في العالم ، وهذا حقًا هدفنا الذي
نريد امتلاك صناعة التجميل